et distribuer aux médecins libéraux on
apprend aujourd'hui que il ya des
inquiétudes autour du vaccin astrazeneca
même si rien n'est prouvé qui a
absolument pas de preuves qu'ils il
aurait des effets secondaires
indésirables mais en tout cas on en
parle
bref tout ça flotte un peu écoutés rémy
salomon alors je dis bien rémi salomon
c'est pas le patron de la la direction
générale de la santé c'est le président
de la commission médicale de
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
ils étaient ce matin chez nos confrères
de france info et il le dit gentiment
mais il le dit quand même c'est le
bordel je pense que le problème
principal c'est la production l'europe
est un pays c'est le premier continent
producteurs de vaccins mais on est dans
une économie mondiale où tout est assez
de multinationales on vend on a démarché
ce que ce qui moi me gêne un peu mais je
ne suis pas le mieux placé pour le dire
c'est qu'au manque de lisibilité à
nouveau je pense que je vous disais tout
à l'heure l'information honnêtes et
transparentes
on manque de lisibilité on a
l'impression de naviguer à vue et
olivier verrons nous a dit hier les
trois prochaines semaines ça va être
compliqué repas alors c'est tout c'est
d'autant plus étonnant que le week-end
dernier souvenez-vous on a ouvert des
vaccinodromes on a mobilisé les pompiers
pour vacciner en masse donc on a une
sentiment de 2,2 de désordre est ce que
c'est un waterloo gouvernementale
laurent joffrin vous qui aimait napoléon
et qui connaissait intimement l'histoire
de ces batailles ou fr lowe's a fait
disparaître
napoléon oui là je vais encore là mais
oui oui ça il ya eu il ya une erreur de
moi qui suis très européen il faut bien
reconnaître que la commission l'union
n'a pas brillé par sa célérité ni par sa
prise de risques puisqu'ils ont pris
beaucoup de retard
si j'ai bien compris parce qu'ils n'ont
pas voulu mettre sur la table
suffisamment l'argent au départ en
craignant de le perdre éventuellement si
j'ai si jamais les recherches
n'aboutissaient pas aussi ses bleus
axens avérées moins efficaces que prévu
donc il ya eu une erreur c'est sûr mais
par contre je m'inscris en faux contre
les réquisitoires qui sont faits contre
l'union européenne tout bout de champ
sur cette question comme sur beaucoup
d'autres il n'y a pas de décision
importante qui se prennent à bruxelles
sans l'accord des gouvernements des
différents pays
un conseil de l'europe conseil européen
qui est composé soit des chefs d'état
soit des ministres concernés et se sont
tous en fête qui ont le pouvoir c'est
pas la commission la commission elle
propose prend parfois des décisions mais
elle dépend entièrement des états
nationaux donc le procès qui est fait en
lenteur à l'union européenne est mal
fondé à mon avis moi je trouve ce qui
est inquiétant c'est comme pour napoléon
cette défaite arrive après d'autres
défaites on a déjà le trafalgar
démasquons et laïque si je déteste et
maintenant on a le waterloo des vaccins
c'est ça qui est inquiétant mais voilà
le sachet d'accord et donc c'est
l'impression qui ne retiennent jamais
les leçons de leurs erreurs passées et
concernant l'europe
moi je pense qu'il ya une vie aussi une
responsabilité du gouvernement français
d'avoir d'avoir un peu bellay europe
europe europe et clément bonnes a encore
bel et la semaine dernière en disant
youpi on envoie 30 mille doses à la
slovaquie innovative état aux affaires
alors que savez qu'il ya un taux de
vaccination plus élevé que le nôtre on
en est à offrir à la slovaquie les
vaccins alors qu'on n'est même pas fichu
de vacciner à ces deux assez de france
est assez de français
de la même façon on est un peu snob on
est arrogant duo là on veut pas du
vaccin russe on veut pas du vaccin
chinois
moyennant quoi comme on n'est pas fichu
en europe de fournir assez de vaccins à
tout le monde et bien y'a plein de pays
c'est très bien d'une européenne qui ont
choisi le spoutnik le qui sont très en
avance par rapport à nous on est une
mauvaise élève
ce qui est insupportable c'est casse
tête qui explique on vaccine à un rythme
soutenu c'est pas vrai et pourquoi on
compte continuer à faire croire ça on
est en retard et il faut l'avouer il
faut accélérer mais il faut arrêter de
dire que tout va bien madame la marquise
et sacchi qui ne va pas qui est qui est
troublant c'est cette communication
c'est de se défendre mais c'est vrai que
la laine oui un mauvais dossier d'accord
alors en fait vous êtes d'accord c'est
après c'est un peu dur par exemple
astrazeneca c'est un peu dur de mettre
ça sur le dos du gouvernement
effectivement c'est pas encore
conséquent donc sicilien s'il ya quelque
chose de grave qui se passe avec ce
vaccin ça n'est pas effectivement la
faute du gouvernement qui a eu un effet
pervers de d'un souci nationale c'est à
dire que on a parié sur sanofi et la
piste suivie par sanofi
n'a rien donné oui pas forcément de leur
faute d'ailleurs en tout cas isolé les
gènes entreprises plus ou moins
française oui mais on savait que ça nous
fine de façon même s'il arrive à fournir
au début 2000 21 ans qui sera pas le cas
ne fournirait pas assez donc on a on
attend du confiseur annoncé que leur
vaccin à 90% étaient sur début novembre
c'est à ce moment là où il aurait fallu
préacheté je parle pas de la france
parle de l'europe
des dizaines de millions de doses en
disant oh là là mais ils sont un peu
chers faut voir à titre après c'était
trop tard je les dis moi même nom comme
non seulement vous êtes d'accord entre
vous mais nos internautes sont sur le
même ton dont vous me direz c'est
magnifique ça fait une chorale on vous
pose la question sur twitter le
gouvernement est hydratée sa stratégie
vaccinale et c'est oui à 80% frédéric
sur twitter qui nous explique que le
gouvernement rate tout ce qu'il
entreprend comme ça au moins c'est clair
ancelin sur youtube la vaccination est
un échec total
c'est un vrai fiasco ajoute chardons
bleus les pharmaciens auront un flacon
cette semaine puis rien la semaine
suivante puis à nouveau un flacon
c'est ubuesque or ce qui est vrai c'est
que le gouvernement essaye de de
distribuer à la fois des vaccins aux
médecins libéraux et aux pharmaciens et
comme il y en a pas assez
c'est chacun son tour nous n'avons pas
assez de doses pour pouvoir réussir à
vacciner nous dit anonyme
et puis pépito sur youtube la gestion de
cette crise est catastrophique
les masques les confinements le
passeport vaccinale les vaccins dire
tout et son contraire en l'espace de
quelques semaines n aide pas à donner
confiance aux gens moi j'ai envie de
défendre le gouvernement parce que sinon
ça tout le monde sera d'accord
laurent joffrin l'un des reproches qui
est fait au gouvernement c'est que on
n'a pas ouvert de vaccinodromes mais
qu'on a oublié qu'en fin d'année
dernière
les français étaient majoritairement
réticents à se faire vacciner et donc
l'idée c'était de dire on va passer par
les médecins de ville parce qu'ils
arriveront à convaincre leurs patients
après coup au printemps quand même les
médecins de ville
oui c'est justement en plus il fallait
se rattraper donc ça à la limite c'est
pas de la faute du gouvernement il ya
aussi une responsabilité des français ou
pas dans ce qui se passe il ya une
responsabilité des anti vaccins d'abord
qui sont une minorité mais qui ont fait
beaucoup de propagande
et puis l'idée s'est répandue que ces
vaccins n'étaient pas fiables
avec cet argument a quitté quand même le
plus étrange du monde ce consiste à dire
on n'a pas de recul
la vie d'avant koffi les nouveaux c'est
un peu de recul
et mais on était face à un dilemme tout
simple c'est ou bien on attendait 10 ans
pour avoir du recul ou bien on faisait
des vaccinations tout de suite or
évidemment l'avion en plus de prendre le
risque de vacciner massivement et au
fond ce qu'il en fait pour l'instant en
bénéficient les comprend le cas d'israël
par exemple ils ont vacciné massivement
et maintenant ils peuvent envisager un
retour à la normale d'ici là la vacciner
10 forte risque de progression de la
population et puisqu'il avait préempté
les jours alors il paraît que netanyahu
ait les relations dans le milieu
pharmaceutique veut at il dit ils sont
laids prévalu et il a dit bon baron
vacciner massivement et ça marche donc
on n'a pas pris assez de risques il est
peut-être que le principe de précaution
ou alors le la radinerie européennes ont
joué un rôle dans cette affaire mais
c'est vrai qu'on est en retard et aucun
doute laissé planer un échec
on a toujours l'impression que le
gouvernement est en retard ils compris
par rapport à l'opinion publique que ce
qui effectivement avec le traumatisme du
gilet jaune et l'impression qu'ils
financent le plus de 500 vaccins on a eu
peur donc on est allé doucement et une
fois qu'on s'est rendu compte que
finalement la population était majeure
et man majoritairement favorables au
vaccin ce qui prouve d'ailleurs que les
propagandes disant vous parlez sont
passés efficace que ça donne à ce qu'on
s'est mis à accélérer et a menacé ce qui
ne se fait pas vacciner des pires
sévices et toujours l'impression que
gouvernement suit au lieu d'anticiper ce
qui devrait être sa mission ou vers les
îles scepticisme à l'égard des vaccins a
été relayé par un serment de leurs
responsables d'accord mais les
gouvernements y la politique la ferme à
écouter en permanence la main on n'a pas
à regarder une dizaine d'agencés l'axé
oui mais c'est pas c'est pas digne d'un
gouvernement qui doit vendre et prendre
des décisions rafraîchira netanyahu
prend cette décision
c'est assez radical il aurait pu avoir
une fronde alors il fait peut-être un
pari d'ailleurs avec une arrière pensée
politique puisque des élections qui
arrivent après mais si c'était raté il
permet enfin il va peut-être et gagne
donc le gouvernement n'attend pas du
gouvernement qui sentent l'air du temps
ce que pense l'opinion publique tels
sondages on attend qu'ils prennent des
décisions et qui les assume et là on a
chaque fois qu'ils ont l'impression
qu'ils il va mais pas totalement au bout
du chemin parce que si jamais quelqu'un
un obstacle et c'est ça qui fait se veut
revoir les me sens le roi louis saez
s'étaient fait vacciner pour montrer que
pour donner l'exemple pour donner
l'exemple
lol c'était la vaccine c'était contre la
variole
cela dit c'est vacciner en plus qu'avec
toute cette manne et vous disiez que
l'extrême droite avait fait campagne
contre le vaccin mais moi j'ai aussi
souvient des premières déclarations du
monsieur vaccin professeur de médecine
éminent faut pas s'exciter trop vite les
effets secondaires que c'est madame
lesquels étaient se résumer à quelques
fièvre oui absolument
alors heureusement qu'il ya dominique
sur youtube qui nous dit de toute façon
les français sont toujours mécontents
c'est désolant c'est vrai de munich et
on arrange pas les choses sur ce plateau
il faut bien le reconnaître
chardon bleu nous dit que les
vaccinodromes pour le h1n1 avait bien
fonctionné
bah oui et non parce qu'il y avait quand
même pas grand monde de ces voix là il
nous est restée beaucoup de doses sur le
dos je voudrais revient à laurent
joffrin à la place de l'europe
est ce que on n'a pas pêché par
idéologie en disant l'europe va
forcément faire mieux que nous alors que
finalement de dans une situation où il
fallait avoir le plus de réactivité
possible bas canton et 27 a décidé
forcément ça prend plus de temps
oui c'est possible je ne conteste pas
mais je pense que les européens les
gouvernements européens se sont dit bon
on aura plus de puissance des
négociations si on se met ensemble ce
qu'est ce que par un raisonnement
stupide pour deux il s'agit de vacciner
300 millions de personnes vous arrivez
devant les la mode est en position de
force en principe mais du coup ça a pris
beaucoup plus de temps et du coup
maintenant on le paye ces personnes
s'est mis d'accord finalement le temps
de se mettre d'accord c'était terminé
des pays avait commencé à prendre des
vaccins encore une fois à l'oeil
on avait trois mois de retard sur les
britanniques exemple dans les rangs des
berges à ce que les ont pas très bien
géré la crise par ailleurs non non non
il se rattrape bien sûr à ce point là
ils ont été plus rapides
est ce que vous pensez l'accès au
buisson que politiquement ce qu'ils sont
en train de se passer est grave
on se souvient des critiques très forte
sur la gestion des masques pendant là le
premier confinement et puis finalement
c'est les choses se sont arrangées
les masques sont arrivés le gouvernement
et le président de la république sont
remonter dans les sondages alors on sait
que dans un peu plus d'un mois une
élection présidentielle ccc en train de
devenir dangereux pour macro où il a
encore le temps
de rattraper si la campagne de
vaccination s'accélère enfin skis et ski
à ces problèmes je crois que ce soir il
doit y avoir un quatrième vaccin qui va
être sans doute mis sur le marché
autorisé en europe et donc et donc en
france et que dans effectivement dans
trois mois il ya quand même 10 millions
de ou 15 millions ou 20 millions de
français qui sont vaccinées dont la
population la plus âgée qui depuis le
début soutient macron de sa manière en
le remerciant de la deûle à protéger
puisque c'est elle qui est la plus
menacée par le virus
c'est pas du tout sûr qu'il y aura un
impact politique ultra négatif au
maquereau parce qu'on en oublie la
gestion on est déjà en train d'oublier
la gestion des masques et des tests
puisqu'à la fin finalement on finit par
faire les choses correctement ce qui est
plus important dans cette affaire je
trouve cette crise est révélatrice aussi
des lourdeurs administratives des
corporatistes vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure des médecins généralistes qui
fait qu'on a qu'on a plutôt favorisé
dans cette affaire des vaccins ou alors
qu'au printemps c'était le contraire
mais alors après c'est les pharmaciens
qui était pas content et puis les
infirmer aujourd'hui qui ajuste petite
dizaine on est dans les zones rurales où
les gens n'ont pas de médecin traitant
qu'est ce qu'on fait on n'a pas le droit
de le faire alors maintenant ça va être
aussi les pompiers donc on voit bien si
l'archipel isation sociologique sociale
administrative de la france dans cette
affaire qui crée cette situation que le
gouvernement n'arrive pas à décoincer
parce que ses corporatismes sont sont
très sont réinstaller et que tout
emmanuel macron premier qu'il est à
vouloir un peu de tout prendre en main
en considérant que les un peu comme
sarkozy que ces mini sont pas à la
hauteur ils se heurtent assez assez
à ces lourdeurs ses raideurs ministre at
il donc de ce manque de souplesse qui ne
cesse de dénoncer d'ailleurs dès qu'il
fait une intervention ou une phrase il
faut qu'ils tapent du poing sur la table
pour qu'on accélère la vaccination avec
plus ou moins de succès mais c'est quand
même dramatique que tous les trois
semaines ce soit lui qui sont obligés de
monter sur le front et s'il le fait
c'est pas pour tirer la couverture à lui
c'est parce qu'il faut le faire pour
donner de la voix parce que sinon tout
le monde retourne dans cette torpeur
administratifs bureaucratiques qui
gangrène la france qui vient d'être
habilités par le toit et des sanitaires
européennes et donc le temps de
retranscrire ça vous française quelques
jours il arrivera l'enjeu fera une
excellente économie comparaison entre la
situation actuelle avec la situation et
il cite marc bloch et son livre c'est
l'étrange défaite en dix ans la
situation française elle est comme
l'armée en 1940 elle est pas prête
elle n'est pas organisée et puis la
société française manque d'un élan
chacun est repliée sur ses propres
intérêts et donc c'est le même état
d'esprit vous trouvez cette comparaison
est accessible par la course et parce
que il ya beaucoup de pays où les choses
se sont pas très bien passées d'ailleurs
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
macron finalement d'empathie pas
énormément c'est que les gens se disent
mais qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire
est-ce qui est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un
dans l'opposition qui a tenu depuis le
début un discours cohérent simples
compréhensibles et la dupont aignan
qu'est-ce qui la lie à une sangle de
cohérence dans son discours
donc je ne suis même plus qu'il a dit
non mais le lien en tout cas l'opinion
ne crois pas que l'opposition a fait
beaucoup mieux et ce qui est d'ailleurs
un peu de monde du bon sens parce que
c'est une épidémie totalement imprévue
c'était un virus qu'on ne se laissait
pas les gens se disent bon ils ont fait
des bêtises mais après tout qui aurait
fait mieux
internet pour terminer en vous réagissez
sur youtube sur ce point de vue où vous
pouvez suivre en direct notre émission
deux avis encore
getty les pays de l'est de l'europe
recommande de leur côté contre les
vaccins ne sait si c'est vrai on grille
à un commando massivement des valses un
russe instable confuse changeant voire
dangereux si l'état est une personne
sera interné d'office militairement
orion et comme ce n'est pas très
équilibré
je termine avec aurélien qui nous dit
sur youtube à la place d'emmanuel macron
qu'auriez-vous fait sur le moment avec
le nombre de morts la fin de l' effusion
à la gestion globale à la pandémie
nous les français on critique beaucoup
mais il faut savoir prendre les
décisions des décisions qui ne font
jamais que des heureuses qui évidemment
n'est pas sain
on chante tout sujet si vous le voulez
bien pour parler de ce que l'on appelle
la com cette culture vous savez cette ce
procédé qui consiste à éliminer du champ
public jean médiatique du champ
universitaire au cip tout ce qui n'est
pas compatible avec le politiquement
correct d'aujourd'hui nous donne un
exemple il y a dans les universités
américaines ou 9 ans sont très fortes
contre l'histoire de l'antiquité qui
devrait être revu de fond en comble
voire supprimées parce que le monde les
coraux gréco-romain préfigurerait la
domination blanche qu'il était
esclavagiste assez difficilement bien et
donc il ya cette idée que il ne faut
plus parler que de ceux qui ne fâchent
pas c'est malheureusement une tendance
qu'il y arrive en france de plus en plus
fortement
jean christophe buisson si on se
focalise sur la diversité on a vu ce
qu'il se passait a lieu mais grenoble
est-ce qu'on peut encore arrêté sa
housse est un mouvement qui va être
ravageur comme il l'est dans le monde
universitaire américain alors je pense
que d'abord aujourd'hui il n'est pas
très répandu en fait on en fait on en
fait de société participe de sur le
garrot on en fait beaucoup sur le sujet
et je pense qu'on a raison parce que
c'est notre rôle de lanceur d'alert
mais pour dire la vérité par exemple les
études des colonials elles sont
réellement vaguement enseigné dans trois
des quinze universités parisiennes et
c'est des petits départements s'est pas
encore quelque chose de massif en
province non plus mais c'est vrai que
dès qu'un événement de ce type on s'y
intéresse on s'y attache parce que on ne
voudrait pas que ça se sache se propage
plus généralement et surtout ce sont aux
noms de ces départements même s'ils sont
ultra minoritaires de l'université qu'on
en arrive à interdire ce qui est quand
même le comble dans universités
interdire lancé sa balle enseignement
d'ailleurs alors c'est plutôt des
séminaires et des colloques que d'un
enseignement après on en parlait mais
par exemple interdire madame agacinski
de venir à bordeaux interdit à mohamed
sifaoui de venir à la sorbonne où allah
ou achille d'être au panthéon sorbonne
où françois hollande d'être acceptées
jusqu'au que c'était à lille sciences po
lille donc on en arrive au nom de ces
petites structures qui sont au sein de
l'université à interdire d'expression de
dialogue de débat parce que c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit finalement si on considère
que par définition essentiellement un
blanc etc ou pas puisque il fait partie
d'une population qui a dominé les noirs
pendant des siècles n'y a plus de débat
possible il ya même plus si négation de
l'universalisme républicain qui consiste
justement à reconnaître les erreurs qui
ont pu être faits dans le passé à les
améliorer a créé des structures
politiques sociales administratives qui
font que il ya moins d'inégalités dans
la société et résumer tout ça à un
identitarisme permanente des uns et des
autres vous n'êtes que blanc vous n'êtes
que noir vous n'êtes que juif vous
n'êtes que musulman etc
c'est quand même la négation de ce que
doit être la france l'université des
françaises le message française et la
culture et pas seulement française la
culture universelle
c'est pour ça que encore une fois pour
moi c'est pas un mouvement
et d'ailleurs il ya toute une gauche qui
est complice de ça et tout une gauche
qui est très hostile à ça et qui se lève
lisez le l'excellent livre dans le
figaro magazine publie des extraits de
eugénie bastié qui s'appelle la guerre
des idées et je n'ai bastié par exemple
un diagnostic est beaucoup plus
optimiste que l'otan dix ans mais il ya
quand même toute une partie du monde
intellectuel encore une fois y compris à
gauche qui est qu'ils se lèvent contre
cette tendance qui vient des états unis
je vous donne un autre exemple de quand
c'est la culture alors qu'on a vu la
couverture du livre de génie bastié qui
est publié chez robert laffont
la guerre des idées et dont vous
retrouvez des extraits c'est que ce soit
dieuze mans sélectionnés dans le figaro
magazine de ce week-end un autre exemple
donc c'était une autre risque au monde
et aujourd'hui alice zeniter qui sur
france culture dit mais madame bovary la
princesse de clèves anna karénine sa cdc
des personnages féminins qui ne
réussissent pas dans la vie c'est vrai
que ça se termine plutôt mal reçu bien
son suicide en un carré et donc et donc
on devrait valoriser d'autres figures
féminines dans la littérature alors elle
ne demande pas qu'on les supprime mais
c'est quand même pas loin
laurent joffrin comment est ce qu'on
fait pour lutter contre ça c'est une
minorité d jean christophe buisson mais
vous savez que ce sont les minorités qui
écrivent l'histoire dans toujours mais
c'est à la gauche de le faire c'est ça
le fond de l'affairé c'est que c'est
essentiellement l'extrême gauche qui
fait ça en tout cas s'il s'agit
d'interdire vous donne empêcher
quelqu'un de parler de ses soutiens et
militaire symbole de la plupart du temps
donc c'est à la gauche de réagir elle le
fait pas assez d'ailleurs je trouve elle
ne devrait jamais beaucoup plus si la
gauche se faire retirer le le thème de
la liberté d'expression au profit de la
droite
je m'inquiète d'autant plus pour son
avenir s'est fait partie de ceux-là
gauche a toujours prêché je parle de la
gauche démocratique évidence je parle
pas de robespierre ou de lénine
je parle de la vraie gauche mon sens
c'est elle qui a défendu la liberté
d'expression c'est elle qui a défendu le
pluralisme la démocratie l'universalisme
de laïcité
tout ça ce sont des valeurs qui viennent
de la gauche que la droite a reprise en
partie mais mais qui viennent de la
gauche donc ses ailes de faire le
travail
alors votez jeunes inquiète de voir
qu'elle ne le fait pas
pas assez les consignes toujours le même
exemple pour être honnête kaczynski
sifaoui moi j'ai protesté dans
libération hautement contre ces
atteintes à la liberté d'expression
alors ça c'est une chose donc tout ce
qui est quand seuls annulé non là je
suis totalement hostile à ça et je pense
que la gauche devrait se mobiliser
contre cette idée là en revanche qui est
des études des colonials qui est les
études de genre ah bon pourquoi pas les
universités à tous et c'est ce fait
partie du pluralisme
je ne je ne souscris pas là m'a beaucoup
de ces idéologies mais il faut
reconnaître à leur décharge que si je
prends l'exemple de l' esclavage
c'est vrai c'est très intéressant
d'esclaves a jusque dans les années 2000
en france étaient minimisés occulter
enfin historiquement normalement on en
parlait est ce un vrai bas si je veux
pas non c'est pas vrai par exemple les
livres d'histoire si vous continuez à
regarder mais skrela jettera moi ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai appris en parler de la
pollution
beaucoup plus que du scav annuel et on
expliquer par beaucoup d'où ça venait et
comment c'était commence à se développer
y compris une règle absolue et bien je
sais pas quel livre vous lisiez mais
franchement l'escalavage a toujours été
étudié les rues de la cité que je suis
plus âgé que vous pour ça mais et et
deuxièmement les ports de nantes de
bordeaux la rochelle de grains c'était
complètement occulté on n'en parlait pas
jusqu'aux jusqu'aux années 2000
je ne m'en comment je la pris alors non
mais à l'école peut-être le plus à 200
mais oui enfin comme et oloron il a
fallu attendre je vois je sûr il a fallu
attendre les 90 2000 pour que on met en
lumière le rôle de ces grandes villes
très prospère et qui ont profité la
traite c'est la limite de bonnes raisons
de revenir là dessus mais voilà vous
c'est la limite de votre discours sur la
nuance entre la gauche et d'extrême
gauche
d'ailleurs dans votre projet politique
je suis curieux de voir jusqu'où vous
irez dans votre alliance avec toutes les
gauches qui se rassemblent aux élections
quand vous allez être retrouvés avec des
écologistes ou des déchets dans
l'histoire s'est allié avec les
communistes
oui mais c'est aussi la condition qui
met d'accord mais ce système sur une
partie de leurs blogs wikis on croyait
que les écolos et que la france
insoumise ils vont abjuré ce que leur
soutien aux études des colonials des
genres etc n'a pas interdire traversée
va pas interdire des colonials non mais
il la soirée cette mesure révélée
de quoi d'interdire ce type d'études
n'ont pas d'anciens faut critiquer c'est
quand eux veulent interdire les autres
c'est ça qui est chrétien mais là dessus
on sera intraitable
ah bon d'accord parfait alors le
prologue mais par ailleurs on parle non
pour revenir sur l'esclavagé ce qui est
intéressant c'est aussi vous allez être
mis à contribution dans les jours qui
viennent il va y avoir une immense
offensive menée notamment par christiane
taubira qui j'imagine fait partie de
votre rêve d'alliance sur napoléon sur
la peau lyon qui a rétabli l'esclavagé
et qu'il doit donc ne pas être
commémorée puisque et il a rétabli ce
cas là je vous allez voir vous allez
être obligé de vous positionner par
rapport aux massues déjà positionné ge
expliqué que s'agissant de napoléon il
fallait faire une commémoration
conditionnelle avec un droit
d'inventaire
oui bah oui oui c'est à dire celle qu'on
croit on fait une expo une pop par
exemple la villette pays à l'expo larry
est en cours là d'ailleurs il n'a pas
commise en exhumer le le document sur
l'esclavagé voilà ça commence non mais
c'est un peu normal de mettre en cause
le rétablissement de la jeune femme aime
à l'époque n'a pas dans une pas dans le
cas d'une commémoration c'est assez
étrange et pourquoi pas mais conversion
c'est pas un hommage
comment dire vinci pas solliciter un
travail c'est quelque chose de tellement
horrible qui ne saurait y commémorer un
peu pas commémorant la personne qui a
rétabli l'esclavagé dont pouvaient
maintenant premièrement cela si on
commémore passe on commémore mais si on
commémore ce n'est pas pour commémorer
commémorer quand même heureux et en
effaçant le les aspects négatifs du
personnage oui mais une manière de le
faire est tout à fait légalement
là on est en train de mettre en avant
les discrets et donc servir la
commémoration et vous allez voir on va y
arriver parce qu'on a dit moi je savais
tu es là ça je pense que dans une ville
comme paris où vous avez l'avenue de
friedland l'avenue de la grande armée
la rue bonaparte le boulevard murat à la
meute rire on va perdre et la gare de
genève
il faut des baptisés tout ça non vous
allez citer tous les noms sauf le nom
qui fâchent lequel napoléon non mais ça
c'est une bombe
vous avez wheeler là dessus c'est la
république à la chute de l'ange se
comptant pires qui a enlevé napoléon les
rues qui a gardé bonaparte pour les
raisons parce que c'est un général de la
révolution voilà c'est toujours
passionnant d'avoir des journalistes
historiens sur un plateau je vous donne
la vie de nos internautes qu'ils
considèrent à 74% que oui on peut encore
lutter contre ces deux camps de cette
culture à l'université général et skype
sur youtube à lui est favorable à ce
qu'on dit soldes les associations et
syndicats étudiants qui prennent cette
idée hall qui prône pardon cette
idéologie
il faut vérifier les travaux des
universitaires qui s'y apparente et
communiquer sur ces questions pour que
les français sachent ce qui se trame
chardons bleus cela va peut-être
déboucher sur un conflit cette histoire
j'espère que ce qu'enfin confirmé en
tout cas il faut impérativement l'arrêté
nous dit boris sur youtube avec trois
points d'exclamation et chardons bleus
ce n'est pas de notre faute l'esclavagé
on va peut-être se repentir des gars de
napoléon pour l'interrogation va on
verra comment s'exerce droit
d'inventaire dans la commémoration ce
qui est vrai c'est que nous avons eu des
témoignages de professeurs d'université
qui nous ont dit au figaro que c'était
de plus en plus difficile pour eux de se
faire entendre une voix différente et
qu'il ya vraiment une forme de
d'impérialisme comme on disait à gauche
à la grande époque réel de sept mois je
le connais que l'autocensure
moi j'ai connu ce type de situations
dans les années 70 à l'époque c'était le
marxisme qui était soi disant ultra
dominant ce qui était pas vrai non plus
c'était plutôt une minorité le marxisme
dont universités dans des universités à
moi elle même si c'était peut-être les
skieurs ils étaient de marque seat et
laurent joffrin on n'apprenait pas
l'esclavagé le marcis des débats
dominant vous avez fait pour moi j'étais
à l'école catholique moi j'étais à
sciences po
par exemple il y avait un professeur ou
de l'été marxiste le cours d'économie
était donné par jean claude casanova
qu'était un libéral et puis il y avait
mais monsieur girardet qui était un
auteur nationalistes qui avaient pignon
sur rue donc c'était pas donné tout ce
qu'on s'était la sensation quand vous
regardez nationalisme il enseignait le
nationalisme midi n'était pas de gauche
c'est vrai oui ça c'est un indice
parisien ou maurrassien du temps mallié
je connais pas bien ça le plus gros
fientes et à aimer il était largement
j'ai d'ailleurs jamais caché
malheureusement la vérité nous oblige à
dire que le coran c'est qu'on ne pense
pas aujourd'hui n'est plus exactement à
l'image de cette diversité
ce soir serait le dire et ce soir c'est
pas cérémonie des césar vous savez que
six mois qu'est ce qu'il ya moi j'ai
piscine oui vous avez piscine va
justement avez vous posez la question
c'est que ça a été compliqué aux césars
parce que on a on a changé tout on a
augmenté la place des femmes parmi les
votants c'est l'été les membres de la
profession qui se prononcent pour les
films on a voulu promouvoir la diversité
est ce que tout ça fait qu'on va avoir
un palmarès inclusif et
intersectionnelle jean christophe
buisson wauquiez tout aussi critique de
cinéma comment vous voyez les choses
oui m'enfin de soissons le palmarès
depuis des années et quand même sur 7
sur cette tendance là donc je pense pas
qu'il y aura une exception ce qui aurait
une accélération il y en a une de fait
parce que les listes le les films retenu
retenu dans une année où on n'a pas vu
beaucoup de cinéma puisque les cinémas
pendant deux mois et demi puis un petit
peu à l'automne et puis terminer les
films qui sont sélectionnés laissent
penser qu' effectivement on va plutôt
honorer ce type de film et ce qui est
bien dommage parce que il y avait
d'autres films qui mon avis mérité un
peu plus de deux nominations que
quand vous voyez qu'il ya trois films
qui je crois qu'ils ont quarante trois
nominations ou trois qui sont réalisés
80 étaient 85 le film d'emmanuel mouret
et
et puis je crois que c'est anthony les
choses qu'on dit les choses qu on
mourait ça c'est mon rêve est le
troisième film ses adieux les cons vaste
programme en général et puis un autre
film s'appelle 2 quitterait ce kit qui
est d'ailleurs quiconque qui concourent
pour les oscars qu'un film français
bon alors je ne vous ai pas pu aller
beaucoup au cinéma comme d'auto s'il ya
un film que vous soutenez ce soir je
suis enfermée dans les séries
malheureusement là je vais au cinéma
un enfant de netflix nommé par exemple
deux goals mon jeu de gabriel le bomin
il a dit la dénomination technique un
peu humiliante et lambert wilson
caresser le minimum mais je pense que le
réalisateur gabriel le bomin qui fait un
très beau travail depuis 15 ans méritait
largement mais évidemment c'est un film
historique c'est un film qui met en
avant de gaulle qui qui incarne une
certaine france un peu classique
traditionnelle nationaliste d'ailleurs
un petit peu quand même
donc là comme par hasard ce film leïla
la fra les honneurs eh bien j'ai
d'ailleurs les nationalistes étaient
plutôt du côté de la collaboration je me
ferai remarquer il y avait des
maurrassien à londres mais c'est dépassé
il y avait quelqu'un d'une autre débat
mais à tous les deux voiliers mais vous
quand on parle de cinéma vous nous
ramenez à l'histoire et c'est pour ça
qu'on vous aime merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis excellent
week-end et ce sera un bonheur de vous
retrouver lundi prochain
[Musique]